let's start today with the topic of
protests many of you have been writing
to me and in different versions asking
do I think there are going to be violent
protests or even riots if and when
Donald Trump is indicted arrested
surrenders arraigned whatever the case
may be increasingly it seems as though
that is going to be sometime over the
next seven days if at all I am I'm
couching all of these things with if at
all so I won't say it every time but
that's the speculation right now and
Donald Trump called for protests in some
of those original truth social posts
that first started this entire
conversation about the arrest Donald
Trump putting protest protest protest
it's time on and on and on and of course
we're a well positioned to be concerned
it's reasonable to be concerned about
violent protests from Maga because
violent protests from Maga are in a way
how we got into this mess in the first
place with what happened on January 6th
of 2021 but
there's a difference the early signals
are that it's really not clear the Maga
people are willing to go out and do the
protesting in this particular case
partially this was evidenced by Monday
evenings completely flaccid pathetic
rally just an impotent rally in lower
Manhattan where like there were more
media people than protesters and there
were maybe a couple dozen protesters we
also had that video from Trump Tower
yesterday where five people were there
holding signs saying Trump won and one
person blew a shofar it's not exactly an
electric atmosphere of protesting in
defense of Donald Trump right now well
Republican senator Lindsey Graham
appeared on Fox and Friends yesterday
and he's using language that raised the
eyebrows of many
and the language he's using is that if
Trump is indicted it will blow up our
country and again many of you taking
this is a sign that he's leading
protesters to maybe behave violently
violently let's listen to what Lindsay
had to say
so are you concerned about the uh
district attorney Bragg Alvin Bragg
indicting president Trump next week in
an unprecedented way and the circus it
would be around that it's going to blow
up our country and this is a bunch of BS
you've had the prosecutor before brag Mr
Vance look at the case and pass on it
you had the U.S attorney in New York say
I'm not going to do it federally there
was an intervening cause other than
Trump running one of the guys in the
DA's office wrote a book very critical
events you should have prosecuted Trump
you let him off and Bragg feels that
pressure he's a George Soros back
prosecutor okay so Lindsay is on topic
with all of the bullet points but that
first line if Trump is indicted it will
blow up our country some are
understanding to be an allusion to
violence that Lindsay is saying go out
there and do the violent stuff now I'll
be very honest with you I find Lindsey
Graham to be a completely deplorable
two-faced individual
he for years now has bounced like a
pinball between playing the rational
Republican who can step back from Maga
insanity and tell things the way they
are sort of like pretending to be Mitt
Romney in a way but then he will behave
uh in ways reminiscent of someone who
should be evaluated psychiatrically for
example his unhinged rant during the
Brett Kavanaugh confirmation hearings
where Lindsay got all red in the face
screaming at the top of his lungs about
how no one has been treated more poorly
and unfairly and unjustly than Brett
Kavanaugh so there are two Lindsey
Grahams Lindsey Graham has no qualms
morally with subtly inciting violence in
the event that Trump is arrested but I
think what the wrench in this is going
to be
is that the Trump people don't really
seem to care enough to actually go out
and protest now this may change if and
when Trump is arrested but in other
times I would have said this is very
dangerous this is a Tinder Box that's
about to explode but right now I'm not
really seeing the evidence of that I'm
not seeing the rage and the engagement
on the ground that these right Wingers
insist is actually out there ready to
come out in defense of trump and again
case in point just look at the turnout
for the protest on Monday which we
covered in lower Manhattan more media
than protesters and even our friend
Jason Selvig from the good liars getting
multiple minutes of being interviewed by
right side broadcasting because they
didn't really have real protesters that
could coherently speak so normally I
would say this is extraordinarily
dangerous now I say people like Lindsey
Graham are dangerous hopefully they're
being dangerous in an environment that
is not actually going to lead to
violence that's the Hope let's now look
at another example of one of these
so-called protests
imagine for a second that you try
logging into your email account only to
find that your password was changed an
hour ago and then you get notifications
of activity from your bank and then your
credit cards that is what identity theft
is like and it's a horrible feeling and
we dealt with it at the show not that
long ago but now I have an app called
Aura which gives me much more peace of
mind our sponsor Aura is the all-in-one
solution for keeping your online account
safe because Aura will scan the dark web
for your personal info passwords social
security number and you get fast alerts
when they find something you also get
fast alerts about credit inquiries Aura
protects all of your devices from
malware or even requests the removal of
your info from data broker sites and
Aura helps you manage what your kids can
do on their devices you can restrict
certain apps set screen time limits set
Focus times when you need them off of
devices is go to aura.com Pacman to try
it free for seven days your login
credentials might already be floating
around out there and Aura will tell you
instantly for free the link is down
below